it's your girl wendy williams on the mic  i am here to stay  wendy williams is not going anywhere i'm  gonna come in like a hurricane  so whitney are you still using drugs he  wants to give you a talk show  millions of people turn on the radio to  listen to me you're the star  i am going to tell it like it is  i'm becoming a real business and i've  been trusting you to take care of all of  them  you're self-indulgent you're  narcissistic you got a coke habit  [Music]  he's having a baby with her before i had  you  i had me and not you nor anyone else  have the power to take away my gifts  [Music]  i will turn this city out a lifetime  original movie  wendy williams premieres saturday  january 30th at 8  only on lifetime